[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna paris saint-germain abend
wünsche ich ihnen wie laufen die
vorbereitung der deutschen fußball
frauen für das em halbfinale morgen das
erfahren wie leicht und sport von
norbert lehmann und chemie und jetzt
blicken wir erst mal auf unsere großen
nachrichtenthemen
kompromiss beim eu notfallplan die
mitgliedsländer sollen ab august
freiwillig 15 prozent gas einsparen
kritische lage in brandenburg springen
die feier von baumkrone zu baumkrone in
der sächsischen schweiz sollen touristen
das gebiet verlassen
und moskau steigt aus russland will
offenbar eine eigene raumstation bauen
und zieht sich aus der iss zurück
was tun wenn russland kein gas mehr
liefert die eu will vorbereitet sein und
so einigten sich die für energie
zuständigen ministerinnen und minister
heute bei einem sondertreffen auf einen
notfallplan das ziel 15 prozent
einsparen bis märz nächsten jahres
freiwillig ein knackpunkt ein anderer es
gibt zahlreiche ausnahmen von caspar
über den kompromiss florian die
vielleicht größte überraschung in
brüssel heute ist dass etwas fehlt der
übliche streit nämlich einigkeit bei den
energieministern sie liegt vielleicht
auch daran dass russland genau das tut
wovor die eu kommission seit tagen warnt
es will noch mal weniger gas liefern
das ist ein politisch motivierter
schritt und aus genau diesem grund ist
es eine sinnvolle strategie dass wir
unsere nachfrage nach gas jetzt
vorsorglich reduzieren
der gas notfallplan sieht vor dass die
eu-staaten ihren gasverbrauch von august
bis märz nächsten jahres um 15 prozent
verringern möglich wurde die einigung
aber nur dank vieler ausnahmen ob für
einzelne länder oder ganze
industriebereiche
die sorge die man haben kann es dass es
so viele ausnahmen gibt dass man so
lange rum rechnet bis dann die krise
irgendwie vorbei ist das war natürlich
fürchterlich fraglich auch ob das heute
beschlossene ziel ausreicht der chef der
internationalen energieagentur meint im
zdf-interview ich wenn alles andere
perfekt läuft dann müssen wir 20 prozent
des gasverbrauchs in europa einsparen um
ein großes problem im winter zu
verhindern
major programm in winter in europe in
brüssel aber überwiegt heute erstmal die
erleichterung scheitern abgewendet
einerseits überrascht die eu heute ihre
kritiker mit einer einigung beim
streitthema energie andererseits ist
dieser beschluss von heute nicht mehr
als eine absichtserklärung
eine pflicht gas einzusparen müssten die
eu-staaten mit entsprechender mehrheit
beschließen diese hürde ist deutlich
höher ob die eu ihr ein sparziel
freiwillig erreicht hängt nun vor allem
an den großen staaten allen voran
deutschland und wie wichtig
internationale zusammenarbeit ist zeigt
sich auch im deutschen gasnetz besonders
im süden wo ein gas notstand die
industrie hart treffen würde eine
besonderheit bayern ist abhängig vom
riesigen gas speicher haidach und der
liegt im benachbarten österreich
bislang liefert ins deutsche netz
künftig soll aber auch österreich
versorgen können wie sehr das die bayern
beunruhigt berichtet alexander pohl
der gas speicher haidach bei salzburg
einer der größten unterirdischen
speicher in europa von hier wird ganz
süddeutschland mit gas versorgt vor
allem bayern jetzt da russland die
lieferungen weiter drosselt erhebt
österreich selbst anspruch auf das gas
aus heimbach wir haben in österreich mit
dem speicher haidach einen der
modernsten speicher in europa und das
ist in einer situation wie dieser nicht
denkbar dass der auf dauer und
systematisch nicht genutzt wird die
frage ob genug gas für alle bleibt
stellt besonders die bayerische
industrie knapp die hälfte seines gases
bezieht bayern aus russland mehr als
andere bundesländer die unternehmen von
der chemieindustrie bis zu den
maschinenbauern sind in hohem maße
abhängig mit blick auf den winter
fordert bayerns ministerpräsident sünder
ein verbindliches abkommen mit
österreich es gibt bislang keinen
völkerrechtlichen gültigen vertrag was
die entnahme und ausgang von dem gas in
dem speicher haidach betrifft bislang
sind absichtserklärungen aber es muss
geklärt werden dass die entnahme nicht
nur für österreich stattfindet sondern
in gleicher weise für bayern bayern hat
auch eigene kleinere speicher noch
werden sie mit gas befüllt teilt das
zuständige wirtschaftsministerium mit in
der vergangenen woche ist der füllstand
von 56,2 auf
59,6 prozent gestiegen experten zweifeln
ob das reicht was das problem darstellen
wird ist einfach dass wir die speicher
möglicherweise nicht auf den füllstand
bringen der uns dann sicher durch den
winter bringen könnte das heißt das ist
momentan die akute gefahr nächste woche
wollen markus söder und sein
wirtschaftsminister den speicher in
haidach besuchen ob dabei bereits
konkrete abkommen geschlossen werden
wird man sie
wer sich ein elektroauto kaufen will
soll künftig deutlich weniger staatliche
förderung bekommen so soll es unter
anderem für autos die weniger als 40.000
euro kosten künftig noch viereinhalb
tausend statt 6000 euro geben für plug
in hybridfahrzeuge also die sowohl ein
elektro als auch ein verbrenner motor
haben soll der zuschuss ende dieses
jahres ganz abgeschafft werden die
einigung ist morgen thema im kabinett
im osten deutschlands verschärft sich
die waldbrand lage nach tagelanger hitze
und extremer trockenheit brennt es in
brandenburg und sachsen im nationalpark
sächsische schweiz weitet sich der
waldbrand aus das feuer war im
benachbarten tschechien ausgebrochen für
bad schandau wurde der katastrophenalarm
ausgelöst in brandenburg mussten bereits
zahlreiche menschen ihre häuser
verlassen
besonders betroffen ist die region um
falkenberg cornelia schiemenz und jan
meyer berichten wasser kann es nie genug
geben in einem waldbrandgebiet landwirt
uwe wonneberger bringt deshalb in seinem
güllewagen zusätzliches löschwasser zu
den feuerwehrleuten in falkenberg an der
elster
helfer aus dass ich die feuerwehren
befüllen kann ich habe an bord habe ich
18 1500 liter wasser die den feuerwehren
natürlich enorm weiterhelfen auch
hubschrauber von bundeswehr und
bundespolizei fashion mit den
verheerenden waldbrand in brandenburg
seit jahrzehnten zu löschen bei kölzer
wird eine ferkelaufzucht anlage von den
flammen erfasst viele tiere verenden aus
drei ortschaften werden die bewohner
evakuiert etwa 300 menschen müssen ihre
häuser und höfe verlassen etwa 20 von
ihnen finden in der veranstaltungs halle
von falkenberg schutz vor den näher
rückenden flammen die brandursache ist
noch unbekannt auffällig ist dass in den
vergangenen wochen mehrfach brände hier
ausgebrochen sind so brandenburgs
innenminister wir sind leider bei
flächenbränden und vegetationsbeginn der
situation dass 60 prozent der ursachen
nicht aufgedeckt werden können ganz
überwiegend ist es menschliche
unachtsamkeit und leider auch
vorsätzliche brandstiftung zur stunde
breiten sich die flammen nicht weiter
aus die menschen dürfen in ihre häuser
zurück die feuerwehr bleibt aber die
ganze nacht hindurch im einsatz
ein urlaubsparadies in flammen meterhoch
züngelt das feuer an mehreren stellen im
nationalpark böhmische schweiz direkt an
der grenze zu sachsen nun haben die
flammen auch auf die sächsische schweiz
übergegriffen
hunderte feuerwehrleute kämpfen gegen
die katastrophe darauf dass kräfte und
mittel begrenzt sind die antwort sich
auch schwierig gestaltet irgendwas
beschränken sich unserem aktuellen beruf
eindämmen das mit viel manpower und mit
hakenkreuzen sparen mit vier
hubschraubern unterstützt inzwischen die
bundeswehr die löscharbeiten in bad
schandau wurde katastrophenalarm
ausgerufen
touristen sind dringend aufgerufen die
gegend zu verlassen
in der sächsischen schweiz soll ein
ganztägiges betretungsverbot für alle
wälder erlassen werden der einsatz wird
noch eine weile dauern und unsere
erfahrung auch von dem bastei plan den
wir vor kurzem hatten da war es noch
mehrere tage danach notwendig dann eben
nach zu löschen ist dass dieser einsatz
bestimmt noch eine ganze weile gehen
wird das feuer ist schwer zu bändigen
weil der wald extrem trocken ist zudem
sind die bäume stark geschädigt durch
borkenkäferbefall starke winde heizen
den funkenflug weiter an so dass es
bislang noch nicht gelungen ist den
brand in der sächsischen schweiz unter
kontrolle zu bringen
deutschland hat der ukraine erneut
schwere waffen geliefert konkret geht es
um drei bereits zugesagte mehrfach
raketenwerfer vom typ maß zwei und drei
weitere panzerhaubitzen 2000 derweil hat
russland wieder ein hafen in der süd
ukraine bombardiert in den docks der
stadt nikolajew sei dadurch die
infrastruktur zerstört worden so qian
mit raketen beschossen land auch ein
dorf der nähe der hafenstadt odessa die
ukraine spricht von einem angriff auf
häuser von zivilistinnen und zivilisten
moskau gibt an dort während waffen
gelagert worden
jan in dieser region odessa ist derzeit
unser reporter dara hassanzadeh über die
dortigen häfen soll in den nächsten
tagen damit begonnen werden das getreide
zu exportieren für viele menschen hängt
ihr lebensunterhalt von den häfen und
dem meer ab zum beispiel durch fisch
fragen der es in diesen kriegszeiten
aber unmöglich was das für einen
fischereibetrieb bedeutet zeigt ihnen
dara hassanzadeh
seit kriegsbeginn steht der
fischereibetrieb von alexander filipovic
stille eigentlich arbeitsplatz von 150
fischern durch die jungen sind bei der
armee die alten heuerten in rumänien an
geblieben sind ein wachmann sein hund
und der chef
im sprichwort sagt wenn du keinen cent
in der tasche hast dann bedeuten zehn
dollar reichtum so geht es los ein teil
des reichtums der ukraine lager
gegenüber in getreidesilos des hafens
jan moors wir dürfen das nicht filmen
aus sicherheitsgründen in kürze werden
von dort die ersten schiffe ablegen
alexanders flaggschiff die kritik muss
im hafen bleiben die kunden aus der
wintersaison vor dem krieg hängen noch
dass die netze auswerfen wenn ihr mehr
minen treiben
ein schiff hat alexander schon verloren
es an katar im russisch besetzten carson
noch härter traf den 63-jährigen die
krim annexion er verlor 70 prozent
seiner schiffe durch enteignung verloren
für die ukraine auch die fischgründe der
krim
das allerwichtigste für mich im moment
ist dass die menschen am leben bleiben
je mehr umso besser und wenn dein
geschäft brach lich das ist schlimm aber
das ist doch ein ganz anderes problem
die alten fischer von juno morus sie
warten im hafen aber der blick auf die
andere seite macht ihnen etwas hoffnung
seit dem angriffskrieg haben sich die
spannung zwischen russland und den
westlichen ländern noch einmal deutlich
verschärft heute nun diese meldung
russland steigt tatsächlich aus der
internationalen raumstation iss aus nach
20 24 soll schluss sein mit dieser
zusammenarbeit im weltraum
stattdessen will moskau eine eigene
raumfahrtstation bauen verkündet wurde
das ganze vom neuen chef der russischen
raumfahrtbehörde die einzelheiten von
thomas concia
die iss einen außeneinsatz im all gerade
fünf tage ist es her dass sie dort
gemeinsam arbeiteten oleg artemow von
samantha cristoforetti ein russe und
eine westeuropäischen fernab der erde
fernab von krieg und politischer
konfrontation statt dessen kooperation
doch auch im weltraum soll damit schluss
sein so will es moskau auch nach
sanktionen gegen die russische
weltraumindustrie
die entscheidung ist gefallen beziehen
uns von der station 2024 zurück ich
glaube bis dahin werden wir beginnen
eine russische weltraumbasis aufzubauen
dazu könnte moskau ein modul abkoppeln
und alleine weiter betreiben hieß es
bisher ging alles gemeinsam russland von
anfang an dabei bei planung und bau in
den 90ern bei der ersten besatzung 2001
us amerikaner zwei russen die
konstellationen seitdem variabel eine
konstante russland ist ständig an bord
immer heißt es zusammen forschen
zusammenleben durchaus mit freude und
gewinn komplett unterschiedlichen
umgebungen aufgewachsen aber dennoch
klappt die zusammenarbeit so gut und das
ist finde ich eines der wichtigsten
dinge die wir von der raumstation lernen
frieden verständigung fortschritt und
nun offen wie es weitergeht mit dem
außenposten der menschheit
und wir kommen zurück nach deutschland
vor einem jahr in würzburg in der
innenstadt greift ein mann passanten mit
einem messer an drei frauen sterben neun
menschen werden verletzt heute entschied
das landgericht der aus somalia
stammende beschuldigte wird dauerhaft in
der psychiatrie untergebracht
petra neubauer berichtet der mann aus
somalia hatte stets von stimmen
gesprochen die ihm das töten befahlen
ausdruck einer paranoiden schizophrenie
entscheidet das landgericht würzburg und
lässt den unbefristet in der psychiatrie
unterbringen die kammer hat es damit
begründet einerseits dass der
beschuldigte zur tatzeit schuldunfähig
war aufgrund seiner psychischen
erkrankung und andererseits damit dass
er hoch gefährlich ist und dass deshalb
die gesellschaft vor weiteren taten
geschützt werden muss taten wie die vom
vergangenen sommer als der mann wie im
rausch auf menschen einsticht drei
frauen sterben es gibt neun verletzte
passanten versuchen ihn in schach zu
halten wir sind schließlich die polizei
fest nimmt die entscheidung des gerichts
für die verteidigung auch ein signal und
mit vorurteilen aufzuräumen dass das
nicht irgendwie ein geschenk ist dass er
jetzt hier als schuldunfähig
erkannt wurde sondern dass hier die
unterbringung im psychiatrischen
krankenhaus nach vollkraft 63 stgb
wirklich wie es auch der vorsitzende zu
recht gesagt hat das schärfste schwert
des strafrechts ist für die verletzten
von damals die nun als nebenkläger
auftraten war der prozess eine wichtige
hilfe wenn den opfern den geschädigten
gehör verschafft wird um für sich dann
auch am ende des tages einen förmlichen
abschluss
erreichen zu können dem mann aus somalia
bleibt die hoffnung dass sein wahn in
der klinik irgendwann in den griff zu
bekommen ist
die lufthansa hat für morgen fast alle
flüge an ihren drehkreuzen frankfurt und
münchen abgesagt betroffen sind mehr als
130.000 passagiere auch an vielen
anderen flughäfen wurden verbindungen
gestrichen
grund ist ein warnstreik des
bodenpersonals bis donnerstag früh der
streik fällt in die ohnehin schon
angespannte ferienzeit an den flughäfen
die gewerkschaft verdi will damit ihre
forderung nach 9 5 prozent mehr gehalt
unterstreichen
und jetzt geht es um ein technisches
meisterwerk oder um ein europäisches
ärgernis je nachdem wen man fragt in
einer dreiviertelstunde wird in der
adria eine neue brücke eröffnet 200
kilometer lang verbindet sie kroatien
mit kroatien genauer gesagt den weiter
nördlich gelegenen teil mit dem
südlichen rund um dubrovnik dazwischen
liegt ein schmaler streifen bosses
gebiet das meiste geld für das projekt
kam von der eu gebaut wurde die brücke
aber von einer chinesischen firma und
das unter ziemlich fragwürdigen
bedingungen butter herbert berichtet
sie ist nicht nur ein kreuzfahrer traum
die pegi schatz brücke verbindet zwei
landesteile und ist ein technisches
meisterwerk denn schon beim bau musste
sie stürmen und erdbeben widerstehen die
pfeiler rannten sie hier bis zu 130
meter tief in den meeresboden
weltrekord sie ist hoch genug auch für
die ganz dicken hätte
85 prozent des baus finanzierte die eu
gebaute aber hat sie ein chinesischer
staatskonzern 20 prozent billiger war
ihr angebot so der sprecher der
auftraggeber 2020
sie versprachen einen viel günstigeren
preis und außerdem wollten sie sechs
monate schneller sein als die konkurrenz
doch es wurde auch klar die chinesischen
arbeiter dürfen ihr kennt nicht
verlassen es gibt hinweise dass sie
nicht ortsüblichen lohn bekommen das
preisdumping spiel war eingehend geprüft
werden konnte das nicht ein ärgernis für
die eben haben ähnliche
arbeitsverhältnisse
finanziert mit eu mitteln das darf nicht
sein und außerdem müssen wir aufpassen
dass wir die die europäische
bauindustrie nicht kaputtmachen wenn wir
den chinesen erlauben mit subventionen
die preise so runter zu treiben
urlaubern macht die brücke das leben
leichter zwei grenzübergänge erspart sie
für die eu war sie eine warnung
chinesischen firmen erschweren nun neue
regeln den zugang zum eu markt
und jetzt zur fußball-em norbert morgen
abend ist also weit halbfinale
deutschland bislang war ja die stimmung
im dfb team richtig super dann aber
heute nachmittag eine richtig schlechte
nachricht stürmerin klarer bühl
torschütze indes wichtigen 1 0 gegen
spanien ist positiv auf corona getestet
worden die anderen 22 spielerinnen
dagegen sind fit die flügel stürmerin
von bayern münchen bisher bei diesem
turnier schon vorbereiten und
torschützen wird dem team fehlen am
konzept der bundes trainerin soll sich
gegen die starken französinnen aber
nichts ändern wir wollen ja unsere
netzplan verfolgen wollen sehr bei uns
bleiben wollen unser spiel durchziehen
und wollen ihnen die räume kommen die
sie uns anbieten werden statt der
zweikampf und dribbelstarken klarer
bühne wird wohl jule brand diese räume
erkunden in jedem em spielen bisher ist
die neue wolfsburgerin für gut
eingewechselt worden gelegenheit die
alternative angriffsformation
einzuspielen bietet sich jetzt den
milton keynes um 1930 beginnt dort das
deutsche abschlusstraining
ja und heute abend das erste halbfinal
spiel england gegen schweden die free
lionesses mit klarem ziel erstmals
europameister werden unterstützt von
fantastischen englischen publikum die
schwedinnen
weltranglisten-zweite ein schwerer
gegner dürfte ein spannendes duell
werden
so weit ist es mit der begeisterung im
lande schon gekommen dass man das
training der englischen frauenfußball
nationalmannschaft auf deren twitter
konto live mitverfolgen kann die löwen
wollen da anknüpfen wo sie beim
last-minute-sieg gegen starke
spanierinnen aufgehört haben bzw weiter
tore am fließband produzieren beim
spaziergang durch die vorrunde waren das
ganze 14 an der zahl aber die
spielerinnen bleiben auf dem teppich
wir müssen jedes spiel nehmen wie es
kommt bescheiden bleiben und nicht
überheblich werden
dreimal hintereinander ist das englische
team bei einem großen turnier zuletzt im
halbfinale gescheitert dieser fluch soll
nun gebrochen werden
ccj rob ludwig hat die dritte etappe der
tour de france der erfahrung gewonnen
die ideen im gewann nach
133,6 kilometer zwischen race & epr im
sprint vor der gesamtführende
niederländerin marianne vos auch heute
gab es wieder einige stürze aber nicht
so folgenschwere wie am vortag und
das war's vom sport dagegen hat noch
kurz zum wetter morgen gibt es im norden
mehr wolken im süden mehr sonne mehr
dazu gleich von ist intelli pass
heute-journal können sie an diesem abend
um 23.15 sehen mit christian sievers
machen sie es gut
[Musik]
schokolade und herzlich willkommen zum
wetter weiterhin ist es in großen teilen
europas viel zu trocken daran ändert
sich wenig denn ein neues hoch dehnt
sich aus auch in unsere richtung ja aber
an der grenze zu dem tiefer sich
allmählich verabschiedet kommt noch
kühle luft und so bleibt es in den
nächsten tagen erträglicher in der nacht
gibt es letzten regen das lässt nach und
es ist größtenteils trocken bei
temperaturen von 9 bis 13 grad im norden
hier spürt man die kühlere luft da
ansonsten im südwesten am mildesten im
rhein main gebiet mit 16 grad und zu
morgen nach norden viele wolken und vor
allem kräftiger wind aus nordwest der
kann auch mal stürmig sein im südosten
einzig hier dann einzelne schauer und
gewitter die können auch mal kräftig
sein aber eben nur lokal und das bei
höchsten temperaturen von 25 bis 27 grad
im süden sonst 17 bis 20 grad bis
richtung die norddeutsche tiefebene die
kommenden tage am donnerstag wieder im
süden einzelne gewitter bis 31 grad
freitag häufiger schauer und gewitter
aber auch wieder nur lokal und damit
eine schöne art